[Applause]
hi drew i am so excited
um please quickly tell us about
america's test kitchen
and how it functions because when i
learned
the rules and what goes into it i was
so impressed yeah so america's test
kitchen we are
a uh a company here in boston that uh we
have about
40 to 50 test cooks we've got two pbs
cooking shows
cooks illustrated magazine cooks country
magazine and we publish about 12
cookbooks a year so
we have an army of test cooks that
basically
test recipes over and over and over
again until we are certain that they're
full proof
we have an army of home testers as well
about 60 000 people around the country
that will make our recipes before
they're published
and give us feedback so we are all about
you know helping home cooks be really
confident about
uh what they're cooking and really happy
with the results so you know what's
better than that
well what are we making today dan so
we're gonna do
a really fabulous roast cod with uh
lemony
garlic potatoes and we're going to do it
in the airfryer
we were initially a little skeptical
about air fryers
but we ran it through the paces and we
ended up really really loving it
and the key is to really think of it as
a small convection oven that sits on
your counter top
the french fries and the crispy chicken
are i think what people generally think
of when they go with air fryers
but it's much bigger than that's why
we're gonna do fish today like who who
would
think that you would do fish in an air
fryer it actually really
comes out so beautifully all right dan
what's our first step
all right so our first step is a trick
that we came up with in the test kitchen
is you want to make a
foil sling to put in the bottom of your
uh of your airfryer basket so i'm gonna
nestle it in here and just make sure
those edges kind of cover over there so
they don't get in the way
this is amazing for getting food in and
out of the basket
and it's also going to allow us to
rotate the food halfway through cooking
which is really important for even
cooking
and then a little bit of veg oil a
little cooking spray
goes over that and on the basket itself
so that is the first step okay so then
we're going to put our potatoes in
and so these potatoes are in butter and
garlic a little bit of lemon zest
so we're basically layering these in
here i was nervous
and excited to cook with you i mean
you're the youngest
editor in the history of cooks
illustrated which really
is a very important institution
all right i've done my potatoes you've
done your potatoes so these go engine
airfryer at
400 degrees uh fahrenheit and we're
gonna go i did a single layer i'm so
sorry am i supposed to double up there
so yes i basically do i don't know if
you can see i do two two layers
one and one and they're just kind of
shingled like that
i think i could listen i want more
potatoes they're so good well yeah
double up on them go as many as you can
okay
perfect so that's going to go in for uh
at 400 degrees for 16 to 18 minutes and
then
rotate it halfway through using that
foil sling
there we go uh 400 degrees right dan
yep that's right so 16 to 18 minutes um
and
we do a rotation halfway through i'm
gonna go 17 because it's in between 16
and 18
is that okay that's perfect dan i'm
really proud to tell you
that uh this is a a new
kitchen appliance uh line that
i have designed and i'm a part of the
company that invented and is putting it
out there it's called beautiful
you don't tend to put them away a lot so
they stay and live on your counter and
we wanted them to be
well beautiful uh you definitely
achieved that that thing is gorgeous
i would i would use it you could put one
in the bedroom go in the office
i mean they're air fryers they're not
just for the kitchen
so while that's cooking and we're going
to do a halfway rotation
and then halfway through its cooking
we're going to handle the cod how do we
handle
the cod that's right so um so i've got
mine and this is a
by the magic of tv here i've got it
switched out so you can see you get this
beautiful spotty browning on top this is
the full 16 to 18 minutes
ta-da you've got one as well um perfect
so that comes out and now we're gonna do
uh we're gonna get our cod on top of
there so these are eight ounce
uh fillets each they're skinless and
mine are a little thin so i've tucked
the tails under which is a good little
tip there as well
so i'm just gonna season this up with um
some salt and pepper
that looks perfect awesome they're going
to go right on top of the potatoes and
you just want to leave a little bit of
space between the two of them
that's going to make it a lot easier
come serving look
ours match dan i know
i can't believe it and then um we're
gonna mix up
real quick this gorgeous compound butter
that's gonna we're gonna dot on top
so you should have some softened butter
there that's a couple tablespoons of
softened butter yeah it's very soft
and then to that we're gonna add about a
teaspoon of lemon zest
and a tablespoon of minced fresh parsley
now this is super flexible if you have
chives you have tarragon if you like
something else absolutely go with that
i'm adding a little bit of chives dan
beautiful that's awesome yeah so we're
just gonna mix that up in a nice little
butter paste little compound butter and
then we're simply going to
dollop it on top of both the flames so
it doesn't have to be perfect
it's butter so it's gonna melt on there
and kind of spread into every little
uh every little crevice and just be
delicious yeah that looks beautiful
that's perfect
um and then so the the next thing is
shingling on a few so
we zested a lemon to get that lemon zest
and then we just slice it into these
nice strips
and put them right on top and that
butter is going to help them stick in
place
this is just it's a gorgeous gorgeous
garnish but they're going to get nice
and browned as well
and the juices are going to drip onto
the fish it's just really
you get kind of magic coming together
with all that it's a lemon
blankie
can i always cook with you this is way
more fun than what i normally am cooking
oh yeah dan come on let's
let's do this um okay so this is 400
degrees so uh and we're gonna go for
about 12 to 15 minutes
um so you might want to go in the middle
there again we're going to rotate it
halfway through using the foil sling
which is really just a such a helper for
us so
dan quick myth buster because i just
read this whole article about you
are not to open your oven while cooking
does the same apply to an air fryer when
you're rotating can not damage the
cooking process or it's okay
no it's totally okay and that's one of
the beautiful things about air fryers is
that they heat up
really really quickly so you take it out
and you lose a little bit heat but it's
just small space it'll heat right back
up so your cooking times
excuse me will still be really accurate
and that is beautiful
um thank you i have to say that
this is so doable that one pot that
one destination where you can be really
focused
and create a beautiful dinner for
yourself that to me
is reality cooking sometimes absolutely
yeah and so many people are cooking for
two people especially now with uh
everyone and you know kind of sticking
to their home all right dan i'm going in
all right i'm gonna give a shot too
you took the words right out of my mouth
the potatoes make this feel
so hearty so warm so abundant
it doesn't feel like diet food it feels
like rich luxurious
a really multi-layered bite and dish
that is a perfect cook on that fish
oh i'm so glad you like it oh my god dan
i don't like it
i love it um i want to thank you dan
souza from the bottom of my
food loving heart air fryer perfection
from the folks at america's test kitchen
is an extraordinary book and really the
perfect accompaniment
to your air fryer and cooks illustrated
really a chef's bible and a beloved
institution of which dan
is the youngest editor-in-chief in its
[Music]
history